und der gigant wie denn jetzt auch schon
geschrieben hat nimmt
nein nein bei mir willkommen
wie immer wurden mir so richtig cool
effect zugesendet wieder über dieses
coole formular dingsbums und unter
anderem auch über das minecraft wiki wo
ich mir wieder ein paar sein
rausgenommen habe und ich würd sagen wir
vorher damit fakten numero eins steht
nämlich minecraft forum und zwar die
implementierung dieser neuen kreatur
also des pferdes wurde von jet beim
erreichen von 10.000.000 spiel verkäufen
auf twitter angekündigt ihr kennt ja
denke ich alle diese pferde minecraft
dieses tolle wunderschöne objekten oder
dieses diese anderen hier oder das hier
oder da viel weniger geld für pferde
wurden hinzugefügt teil minecraft zehn
millionen mal verkauft wurde und sap
gepostet das was ich jetzt mal
eingeblendet coordination of skate jam
twenty copies to go go down voll und es
hört auf und danach hat er geschrieben
minecraft pc link eingefügt wo man dann
sehen konnte dass da einfach sondern
fährt ist nicht mal mein kopf sondern
einfach ein pferd und das war quasi
dahin denen den jet damals gegeben hatte
dass eintracht fährt hinzugefügt werden
und so was muss ich echt sagen dass
nämlich einfach dran weil minecraft ist
ein extrem cooles spiel und hatten
extrem cooles entwicklerstudios männer
allein diese tatsache dass ich vor zwei
folgen glaube ich vorgestellt habt das
nur das werfen von eiern hinzugefügt
wurde weil ein typ gesagt hat ich es
nicht wenn du das schon mega gehört lege
ich jedenfalls fand ich das ganz cool
und habe deswegen mit reingenommen das
perfekt malz und jetzt kommen noch zwei
die zweite sache ist mir selber ein
gefallen und zwar bis grad mal schon
teil satellite gemachtes ponor einen
zombie und sport eben einen schneemann
und falls euch wundert ja das ist ein
kürbis das ist nur ein rotes geschenk in
diesem text per jedenfalls ist jetzt
jemand attackiert natürlich anderem ob
es macht aber natürlich keinen schaden
aber er hält die auf jeden fall von sich
fern
allerdings erwirbt die schneewälle das
sieht man ja da kommen so schneller raus
oder das sieht man zumindest wenn man
mal so guckt der wird auf jeden fall
schneebälle auf den zombie aber wem auf
den sound hört dann ist das der sound
als wenn ich einen bogen pfeil dingsbums
schießen würde nicht wie ein schneeball
wenn ich mir nämlich jemals schneebällen
er hörte schon der sound von
schneebällen ist so ganz normal hub und
wenn ich dann hier wird man bei dem ganz
normalen
schneemann höre wie der seine sonst von
den schnee mal ist einfach von
bogenschuss ich kann mir das nicht
erklären ich weiß nicht warum und warum
das noch nicht fixiert oder butter 6
also ist oder wie oder was oder warum
aber dass auf jeden fall fällig nummer
zwei kommt von luca dritte sache habe
ich im internet gefunden als ich einfach
so rum gesucht hat und dann habe ich
doch ein ganz altes minecraft bild vom
schwein gesehene 6 grad schon
eingeblendet und zwar hat das schwein
die augen so ein bisschen innen und
spielt so ein bisschen und zwar ist dass
die grundsätzliche generelle allgemeine
zuerst veröffentlichte published version
eines schweins in minecraft zu anfang
haben sich die entwickler gesagt okay
wir machen und das wird so aussehen und
ihr seht ja sogar kleines dieses kleine
bild wo diese bäume und das gras mittag
uns ist das ist sogar so in minecraft
umgelaufen das sah so aus also ein
bisschen schäbig auf jeden fall ganz
witzig dass es halt so dir da noch
bilder von gibt von diesem ersten sachen
die in minecraft damals damals damals
damals damals in minecraft sitzt damals
kredite da ist in minecraft vor einiger
zeit gab und dieses schweinchen mit
denen nach innen gedrehten schwarzen
pupillen ist auf jeden fall eins davon
ist ein ganz simpler kleiner
interessanter fakt und ich wollte euch
einfach zeigen dass nicht alles ganz am
anfang so war wie es jetzt in minecraft
ist weil viele fangen also jetzt erst so
mit minecraft an und die fragen sich
dann so hin ok und dann gehen sie mal
damals ich mein ich kann euch nur
empfehlen im neuen lounges ist echt cool
gemacht man kann einfach mal drauf
klicken so ja welche version man spielen
möchte spielt doch einfach eine
alphaversion oder so ich hab damals mal
let's play gemacht ich glaube das ist
minecraft lost wo ich immer eine 40 50
minuten folge gemacht hat und dann immer
eine version höher gegangen bin
aber das ist auf jeden fall extrem groß
gewesen weil man konnte zum beispiel
nicht sprinten nicht essen und alles
möglich so richtig krasse sache das war
noch viel härter dieses spiel und ja das
ist auf jeden fall fängt nummer 3 bevor
ich jetzt auch zweifel bleiben auch
gleich schon bei der nacht und zwar
schon unten links kann objekt nicht
erzeugen aber ich kann einfach mal wenn
ich jetzt hier auf drei angeblich kamen
ja meine koordinaten eingegeben so dann
gebe ich jetzt einfach mal die
koordinaten und ihr seht schon ihr wird
eine riesige gigant hergestellt
der einfach vom spiel quasi gespielt
dies habe ich ja schon mal öfters gesagt
dass man mit diesem befehl batterien
habe ich eigentlich zusammen scheint
muss groß geschrieben denn sonst geht es
nicht und 100 764 1930 sind die
koordinaten hier und jetzt kommen wir
nämlich erstmal zum effekt weil das ist
dass man diese giganten erschaffen kann
habe ich ja schon mal gesagt allerdings
kennt es wenn ich irgendwelche
erwerbbaren reil trank nämlich mal und
ich nehme ein schadens trank und zwar
wenig schadens tragen auch einen zombie
werfe wisst ihr das sind untote leute
das habe ich schon ganz oft gesagt die
nehmen dadurch kein schaden allerdings
wenn ich einen werfer antrag der heilung
auf sie drauf werfen dann werden sie
quasi geheilt und das nehmen sie als
schaden war dementsprechend sterben sie
nach der zeit wenn ich allerdings ein
wert waren krank der schaden auf diesen
giganten drauf schmeiße ich muss denn
hier unten drauf schmeißen weil da oben
reagieren die ähnlich auch wenn ich den
oben schlage man musste nämlich unten
raus schmeißen
dann nimmt der schaden unter einem wert
waren trank der heilung heilt es ihnen
quasi also beim giganten ist es komplett
unterschiedlich zum zombie also das ist
quasi die gleiche texturen in groß aber
sollen die ganzes quasi vielmehr steve
als irgendwie der jeweils der hier nimmt
eine heilung an wenn man den mit schaden
abwirft und der hier einem schaden wenn
man die mitteilung ab und dieser hier
dieser hielt sich wenn man die
mitteilung abwirft und schadet ein wenn
man ihn mit schaden ab wird da bin ich
eigentlich mega interessant also ein
gigant soll ja eigentlich nur ein zombie
in groß sein dann finde ich das
eigentlich auch ganz gut wenn so eine
einheit gebe mit den schadens tränken
und so dass ein schaden nimmt weil das
wäre schon ganz sinnvoll aber der kleine
hier ist sich wohl einfach zu mir
verbunden und das ist auf jeden fall weg
nummer 4 der stand auch um minecraft
wickie und finde ich mega interessant
aber jetzt kommt erstmal zum fünften
dieser fünf effekt handelt nämlich auch
von dieser person die hier schon rum
stehen sehen und zwar wenn ich einen das
schreibt mir den nils wenn ich einen
giganten angreife machen sie keine töne
und sie droppen auch nicht also ich kann
es jetzt mal machen wir natürlich ich
hab's euch gezeigt wenn ich oben drauf
schlagen kann ich sogar in den giganten
rein fliegen da passiert nichts ich gar
nicht boxen oder so wenn ich allerdings
ein junger boxer hatte schon machen die
gleichen töne wie ich wie steve wenn ich
irgendwo unter fall wenn ihr das mal
sehen wenn ich mal hier in den games
null gehen von hier unter fall achtet
man auf den ton
das genau der gleiche tun wie wenn ich
hier auf den giganten aus schlage der
gigant wie denn jetzt auch schon
geschrieben hat nimmt
nein nein das macht natürlich gar nichts
wir bauen einfach neuen giganten da
hinten und wenn ich den jetzt
beispielsweise mal goethe seht ihr auch
schon der gigant lässt nicht ob ich
wirklich die ganze kritik als ort das
heißt müssten relativ schnell gehen
der drops auch nichts airdrop ein
bisschen erfahrung aber sonst auch keine
items also ich finde beim giganten kann
echt noch viel verbessert werden erst
bot natürlich nicht so im spiel sondern
man kann ihn nur mit diesem befehl
spawnen aber ich finde trotzdem ecke er
sollte ansporn so als portion sondern
auch ganz viele bekommen andere items
und der soll andere sounds man mit den
tränken und so also war eine sehr
giganten reiche für heute
gigantomanische fertigt nahezu was habe
ich das nicht rein luca wenn du das
nachdem schmitz sieht nun eine anwendung
ist ab jetzt schon zu viel geredet habe
damit würde ich jedenfalls sagen meine
lieben freunde war es das mit der
minecraft ex folge für heute ich hoffe
euch hat es gefallen ich hoffe ihr
fanden die facts gut wenn ihr cool
effect habt die dann eventuell in der
über übernächsten folgen in der
übernächsten folge dran kommen weil dann
bin ich wieder aus dem urlaub zurück
dann tableaux get the description etwa
beschreibung da steht ein formular was
sie einfach kurz ausfüllen müssen da
auch infekt reinschreiben und euren
namen und alles mögliche und bla bla bla
und sofort ich will sagen es euch
gefallen obwohl ich meine bewertung
freundschaften in die kommentare
wie viel uhr es gerade weil das ist
immer recht interessant wenn ihr das
schaut und sonst würde ich halt sagen